the countdown is nearly over starting  tomorrow hundreds of millions of voters  will decide the future they want for the  European Union ballot papers have been  prepared across 28 countries like at  this regional polling hub in eastern  France voting equipment including ballot  boxes have also been dispatched across  the dozens of Greek islands that means  one thing ferries distribution the head  of the vote began several days ago the  elections have taken months of  preparation including huge online  campaigns people of all political colors  have been encouraging Europeans to get  out on polling day and make their voices  heard  many Europeans living abroad have  already voted by postal ballots to be  counted after the polls close in some  countries like tech-savvy Estonia  citizens can vote online from the  comfort of their home or sauna choose  your future vote in the European  elections from the 23rd to the 26th of  May  [Music]